we're going to prove this identity this
is the first thing that I'm going to
show you about how to yachts are can
help us now do you remember when we did
trig identities before camp I told you
that broadly speaking there were three
different categories of trig identity
proof that you had to do there was the
one that you had central equals
complicated right so that is you start
with the copper-kidd side and you work
on up working it until you make it
simple and then you say cool I'm there
I'm done right another cone is when you
had complicated equals complicated right
it's like our product sighs look
disastrously messy so I suggested to you
okay we'll just cut up work with both
sides if you can't immediately see what
you should do and eventually they want
to connect right the hardest kind of
mode was where both sides are simple and
where everything looks nice and neat and
there's not many terms and what you have
to do is you have to make one of the
size Mexica like x you know something
over something or add something and take
away something in order to make one side
more complicated and then you can do
some identities does it like the plastic
around it or wherever and then in comes
into this okay and when you have a look
at this is exactly what I'm talking
about
have a look at both sides it's as simple
as it gets pretty much there's no like
reciprocal identities nothing is squared
there's no obvious place where you're
like oh I know what I should do next
this is kind of chicken when you
finished going through one of these
processes so what do you do you can
solve this without T results and I will
let you I'll leave that as an exercise
to read after you try and work out how
to do that possible but remember I said
to you the whole point is to hijack your
skill with algebra to try and help us
with trigonometry okay so have a look at
this what I'm going to do is I'm going
to say that I'm going to introduce this
substitution I'm going to say it let T
equal ten feed upon soon I should point
out you've got to do it every time
you've used to yourself because you're
about to talk about team
fifteen of them okay sort of introduce
it once you've done that you can
translate the question completely into
algebra and leave the trig identities
behind let's start with the left hand
side if T is equal to this then all of
these things I've written in my box all
of the T results are true you don't have
to restate them all over again
that's all you need to say but you might
like to have them there on the side so
if you've written that down so we have
that on a page that you can do as well
I'm now going to write the left-hand
side in those terms so on the top I've
got 1 minus 1 1 1 minus 2 u squared 1
okay by the way just a quick note I've
said to you before reference sheet is
there but even though it's like I said
you'd like a don't rely on it I couldn't
rely on excited habit I have to learn
how do I remember like what about tricky
things to remember is which one is which
is it one potty screen on one minus T
squared or is it is it the one minus on
the top is it easy way to work out like
it's kind of obvious which one has two
numbers are in a right-angled triangle
right this is meant to be the adjacent
side this is the hypotenuse how do you
know which side in any given triangle is
the hard one is there are two ways you
can know
yes just one you okay there's there's
the right angle but a more helpful
definition in this case if the
hypotenuse has to be the longer side
right legs can't construct the triangle
a right angle triangle with a shorter
hypotenuse now have a look at these two
which one is going to be the bigger one
it clearly has to be this one right T
the amount of T is T Square has to be a
positive number so if you add it you're
going to make it longer if you subtract
you're going to make a shorter so this
is just a little sort of mental shortcut
for you rather than having to turn to
the referee find it so you remember you
straight away
divided by what's a little bit
- tea on one plus t-squared because they
my buddies now I'll grant you it looks
like a bit of mess right now but that's
okay we've had lots of practice with
algebra perspectives hey look you got
fractures on fractures what do we
usually do - I should multiply to you by
something what would be one thing that
gets rid of all my factional graduate
learned that met denominator right there
let's do it but more mature this is a
give me how much - 1 plus the T squared
multiply that through then I'm going to
subtract just watch out for your double
negative there 1 of minus T squared you
see how I've got rid of that denominated
it so far so good
what's going to happen on my syllabus
multiply this by 1 plus T so just
because 2t doesn't it okay are you happy
with what I've done so far that's what I
really do I will actually point out
maybe if you got another card you want
to identify this when you work with T
results because so often you get this
one plus t-squared denominator that
happens like a B so the time at least
very frequently the first thing you're
going to do is multiply by one point Z
squared or 1 + 2 squared that's on a
table top of the bottom okay
you'll see later on this lesson even
when you're doing your letters you see
like when you view your sabbia gradients
you still do this okay let's collect
some light tones what are you getting on
your own sweetie squared + 1 - 1 they're
gone this is a T squared minus mu T 2 n
2 Z squared is back that's divided by 2
T so now I have a simplified version
okay now pick it up it's straight
remember I said to you the hard thing
about when an identity has simple equal
simple is you have to Rack your brain
through all those hundreds of thousands
of trig identities you know now you like
which one do I use but here
how much thinking did you do about like
is it the Pythagorean one is that one -
consequent or once cos squared how much
think you did you have that
acquire that knowledge enter done
you were just through algebra you can
always do that on autopilot you don't
have to think very creatively you can do
this very efficiently I'll go to left
hand side it's simple what do you think
I should do do
I should work with the right exercise I
hold your hand with the left hand side
can you work for me I'm done
it doesn't require your call how much to
get it which even though something admin
would slightly messy like you've got
fractured bone fracture that's usually
gross okay because of they can make sure
the tubules they fall out quite quickly
right in yo Wallace is canceled they
better because you should be vicars to
be identical and the question was our
rate twice you get to here right the
right hand side equals on that right so
do I have to do like repeat the whole
person should go backward the answer is
with T results this is what I'm asking
you places where no you don't have to
you don't need to reverse engineer your
algebra because the algorithm plays you
out completely clearly whereas in trig
identities when you're working with
Patrick Orion isn't Ebola not always so
obvious
okay so at this point I'm sure that the
left hand side is something I've
operated what it independently that's
okay I've done the same at the right
very cool
that's all I was recorded to show
someone done okay